hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to ultimate custom night the
official next game in the five nights at
Freddy's series isn't what you would
have expected this is a test a test that
anybody who's stupid enough to call
themselves the king of five nights at
freddy's to see if they really are as
good as I save it I am and looking at
this I think that maybe I'm not gonna be
because this right now set to uh what is
called 50:20 mode and just to give you a
taste of what 50:20 mode is like it go
I'm gonna hit go I haven't done this
before but I'm almost a hundred percent
positive that nothing good is gonna come
out of this because I haven't even
played this at all so yeah can't you
fish wide if I have to catch a fish I
don't know I don't know anything about
this you know screw it I'm not even
gonna read it you're just we're gonna go
we're gonna go for hey hey I'm back hey
guys how you doing I don't remember
anything how to do nothing of no sorts
so um so far
we're dead am i alive or dead
and there you go 17 seconds I'm pretty
sure that's probably the best the best
time I'm gonna get for a long long long
time yeah uh-huh oh wow
take this item for your troubles thank
you oh thank you for that okay screw
that and screw this so we're gonna work
our way up to that see I don't even know
how these characters work they are a
little bit different than they were in
the other games in this series Fred here
Freddy Fred boy Fred man threadbare
listen Fred he doesn't work the same way
he did before he approaches from the
left hallway and he gotta shut the door
before he's getting to you and he moves
faster than the building gets warmer and
that's a whole nother mechanic that you
don't even know about bonnie is now
sharing pirate Cove with foxy but he
doesn't like to be looked at which is
wonderful and probably while he ripped
his face off chica doesn't care if the
music box has wound up but she gets
tired of the selection playing foxy is
the same but he puts himself in your
Asif piece by piece toy Freddy citizen
parts and services but playing five
nights with mr. hugs on one click on the
cams a toy Freddy to monitor them be
sure the appropriate hugs it would
prevent mr. hugs from jump scaring him
why would I care about that why would I
care about that I have to not only look
at my monitor but I have to look at
another characters monitor
it's so stupid okay anyway we've got a
long way to go but I'm gonna show you
I'm gonna show you in this episode here
we're going to learn about everything
we're gonna learn from start to finish
top to bottom we're gonna learn
absolutely everything that there is to
know about each and every one of these
characters we're not gonna get to know
them on an individual level and that's
gonna help us through this we're gonna
take this methodically peacefully
doodlee it's gonna be great make sense
good great gotcha okay
and before I get started I do want to
say that I had intended to play this
game earlier but obviously with what
happened to my niece Miranda and me
flying back to see my family I was
unable to get to this like family is
obviously more important than playing a
game that even if I've been waiting for
it to come out for a while I wanted to
make sure that I was with my family
first I just wanna say thank you for
allowing me to have time with my family
I'm doing a lot better than I was III
don't think I'll be a hundred percent
for a while obviously when you lose
someone close to you in your family like
is you're gonna feel that for a while
but I am better now and honestly I want
to make videos I feel good when I am
making videos and I feel like it feels
more normal when I'm doing it so I'm
gonna get back into this and I just want
to say thank you guys so much for
letting me take time and all the
goodwill messages that you sent out to
my family especially when his dad Mike
in that the world and you know it means
the world to me I just want you to know
that so with all that being said we're
gonna get into this so I'm gonna start
out by taking the first four characters
I think it's like symbolic to go after
the the first original group here I mean
golden Freddy technically was a part of
that in the first game but I'm just
gonna yeah you know what let's bring
golden Freddy in here so golden Freddy
occasionally appears in your office
throw in the Freddy mask or pull up your
monitor quick bucket so don't look at
Bonnie look at foxy change the music
keep track Freddy and don't look at
golden Freddy then it's just like the
original right what what could be so bad
about that let's do it
all right I don't remember all the
controls you're gonna tell me the
controls you're not gonna tell me the
controls how okay Foxy's in the coat hi
you weren't supposed to be fine Foxy's
in The Cove Hey okay that makes me feel
better all right let's take a look at
this bad boy so it shouldn't be so bad
hey buddy hey buddy hey okay oh wait
that's it
oh that's okay that's that's that that's
what reset ventilation okay that's whoa
whoa hey whoa whoa sorry sorry did I do
something bad how do i how do I get the
door The Doors don't doors don't seem to
work The Doors don't doors Oh noise
that's that's a thing that's okay I'm
sorry
god dammit I'm sorry I should look at
that but then if I leave oh I'll take
the coins please I like that that's good
good what in the heck in hell I'm sorry
okay thank you I forgot about the pots
and pans [ __ ] over there alright
thank you for that douche Oh didi repel
prevent didi from appearing
well thank you well thank you for that
that is thank you thank you so much that
is nice
thank you again I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to beat this but I want to
at least learn and how these work and
why can't I get my [ __ ] here
okay sure tell me what buttons to push
what did you have to do SH me with no
buttons oh I forgot fungi fungi needs to
be there okay fungi I forgot phone guys
apart of this [ __ ] I did the thing
okay there's F coins here big s oh wait
the music ah need to change that how do
i how do I change the music how do I
wait how do I change chain oh alright
got that all right you got that you're
in there don't look at me so in the
there's there's there's coins in the
world and then you can I remember you
can spend i got a deep hi how do i all
right you're fine but where's where's
okay there's Freddie how do I close the
doors I don't I still don't know how to
do the thing that you were talking about
with closing the door I need to get
power how do you do this AHA - how do
how do you closed door Daisy the button
Oh
well wait no oh so ah these these change
those okay Freddy you're a common that's
a good thing and then foxy tit sprinkles
okay there's got to be like hope oh it's
WASD okay so I got that let's let's we
need the power generator that's a for
goddamn certain okay we need the power
generator oh we are not work word bad
get bonnie is over there that's it's
fine
baby seven elation okay that oh thank
you oh do I
I don't see a button um how do I pay see
oh [ __ ]
okay Thank You Freddy thank you for that
I like the way you massage me from my
neck okay so I think I'm getting it so
what I'm gonna do is I didn't win that
one that's fine it's fine that I don't
win them it's fine that I don't win them
what I want is the ability to learn
about them makes sense I want to learn
about them so what I'm gonna do now
there's new mechanics right so I'm gonna
put in all of the ones from five nights
at Freddy's 2 so 1uu I'm not gonna keep
it at 1 I'm gonna I'm gonna raise them
BB JJ was actually a secret a secret
character that I believe was in five
nights at Freddy's 2 but I never
actually saw so I believe that was all
from five nights at Freddy's 2 any more
than there's more mangle where's mangle
bangle
where's mangle oh no there's mangle all
he wanted you for fight you wouldn't
know more than that wonder wonder warden
crazy fungi your stutter wasn't there
okay apparently that was Oh golden
Freddy who's there - okay that's
probably enough there was also the
endoskeleton but I don't believe that
that's here oh yeah I know who I'm
missing where's where's Freddy where's
five nights at Freddy's - Freddy
all right we're gonna put Freddie in
there just because he's not there from
here yeah where's Fred boys okay I'm
gonna keep them all we're gonna do them
all at three just to make it a little
more aggressive okay in summary toy
Freddy he's in parts and services I got
a look at him and I got to play a game
inside a game - a toy Bonnie fredbear
mask sneaks into your room to fool him
and make him go away okay okay that's
fine okay same with chica okay toy
Bonnie and toy chica are exactly the
same you use the Fred mask to get away
from
unlike other animatronics and the vents
want mangle breezes the vent opening
never leave these vents near to prevent
her from making it that far
okay that's good bebe try to sneak in
through the side vent close the side
been wait till you hear a thud if Bibi
slips in he will temporarily disable
your flashlight that's not so bad
sneaking through the side close that
side ven wait - here - thud disabled
door controls temporarily chica climbs
through the air vents make sure maybe
gets but may get stuck when trying to
enter your office use the vents near to
prevent her from reaching the opening he
will attract you in you will appear in
your office poised to attack throw on
your Freddy mask to make him leave again
ok he's he enough keep the music box
wound or you'll come get you boyfriend
golden Freddy okay that didn't make any
sense but ice it sets up through it I'm
gonna go for it so I got it what I got
to do is I gotta get the controls better
because I don't remember what the
controls worth the girls went by they
didn't come back so these are all the
door controls I put it on power it's
making noise but that's okay I know
that's handy that's really handy that's
that's so handy that's real handy why
wouldn't you give that that's so handy
Oh click a path to send an audio alert
who who said that who said they promised
to never leave who said leave 'no but
never promised i gotta keep that oh
gotta keep this really cranked my god oh
I forgot you were playing a game
Oh what you got mad at me or were you
scared were you scared as I was or why
what was the deal with that okay
then fine fine Freddy boy Freddy I've
got big goofy fingers and I'm just a big
dumb idiot I wish that I was as cool and
or smart as you okay where's parts and
services okay you oh he's right there
that's so cool and terrible that's gonna
be awful I didn't turn on the power god
that's oh gosh [ __ ] okay well I didn't
know about that all right
um you gonna you coming down the left
hall area which which way is it coming
where's it coming from Oh likes you so
how do you favor okay thank you can I
get ahead back to some proof oh that's
real nice did we do what did how do i
why do I have you're a real shaky there
oh [ __ ] ah oh I'm dying I am dead okay
yes
but I'm not afraid of you that the voice
not my voice with the puppet you're not
afraid of me and my purple guys this my
hell is this my personal hell that I've
been put in forever because I'm in hell
this is my hell
but it's my hell Oh Lady repelled I
don't know daddy does what does Dini do
what does diddy do why is this at a nine
get you back down you [ __ ] kid don't be
9 why would you do that we're gonna try
that again I'm gonna try each of these
twice each time I get a little better at
it I still don't want the other buttons
do okay and that's Z is flashlight okay
that's that door said to that I'm gonna
wind up the music books
okay we're gonna look at you what am I
looking for here what am I trying to
help you do I see mr. hands over there I
don't know what that's gonna do for me
Oh game over already then what am i
there we go I guess I did too how do i
smoke Cena what are you oh my god don't
just don't do that just don't do that oh
okay I got that door closed but I don't
know what its gonna do for me there's ah
[ __ ] off you shaky bastard okay yeah
there you go
whoa okay so Vince who or what or why is
why do I do with you huh this game is
totally rigged now I'm gonna try that
again it's hot damn it what do you do
click the cams on the toy line then be
sure the appropriate door is closed to
prevent oh okay so I actually got a
closed doors in there I imagine it's the
same controls as the ones out here if
it's not then
all right you wait no no how do i how oh
the green ah that makes sense that makes
swings that makes plenty of spoons
give me that that makes the most once
I've ever heard those so if there's a
reason to go through here but I imagine
on 50:20 mode you're never ever ever
ever gonna have enough time to go
through and do all this nobody alright
it's gotta be no even real vibrate II
appreciate that about you I really do
priest been super hard but listen I
don't want a power AC oh hell yeah to
the power racing okay I got to get used
to the numbers for those because I gotta
look good I have some power please this
horrible accent I've ever heard but the
best a conductor Hey whoa that's fine
you be annoying but that's fine right
I don't know what I just bought about a
decoy oh that's not good what are you
doing you still fine okay you're still
fine
you still find you blow my mind hey
plastered hey hey hey bastard get the
Frick out of here okay I don't know what
the other buddy F oh wait what no way
all right okay four is power AC whoo
what
okay get that back down to a sweet
savory temperature reset the ventilation
okay they're not on the way yet okay
let's get back to the power bi Oh touch
your bird all right all right not touch
all over
od click so what does I mean the puppets
talking to me the puppets never talked
to us before who are you your kid
there's some lore about that somebody
get matpat on the horn somebody be good
luckily as far as me okay so I think I'm
getting that but I need to know the
goddamn keys but I'm learning it I don't
want to I don't I've got is my big brain
you see this big brain up here it's got
it all so we're gonna no not you yes you
you phantom phantom phantom phantom no
no no no afton spring-trap half didn't
bring two different dudes okay so this
is going to be five minutes of Freddy's
3 he makes his way okay spring-trap
makes his way towards the vent opening
embedded in the wall in front of you
when he's poised to attack it we will
see his face looking down at you close
event send him away
phantom angle you will see him on your
monitor quickly close it or it will
appear in your office and create an
audio disturbance phantom Freddy shine
your flashlight on to cause him to fade
away if you don't evil jump-scare you
giving it time for enemies and events to
sneak into your office he causes him to
appear faster when he appears in your
monitor quickly closer to change the can
do
boy does jumps good okay so two people I
need to avoid one do I need to shine the
flashlight on and one do I need to just
stop from getting to me something crank
these guys up to five just to throw a
wrench in the mix I'm gonna bring the
phone guy back yes cuz I feel like it I
like the challenge alright let's go for
it
so I'm gonna get better at the controls
because a lot of part about this game is
going to get better at the hotkeys
because if I can't get better at the
hotkeys
ah yes is the monitor oh go away come
back another day come back another day
alright so the rest just in the hell is
an event system so everybody else is
just gonna Hey shut up
how about you shut up there huh how
about you shut up so these points into
the marionettes not there was this
that's just happening because it's
happening oh go go what come back
another day whoa
coming back another day all right you
you [ __ ] are gonna be a bit tricky
you're gonna be a bit tricky Joe what do
you mean whoo-hoo how am I supposed to
know how like how am I supposed to know
how am I supposed to know who you just
threw in the rip who who did you throw
oh hi what is that why is that happening
who I don't remember why or how I don't
I don't know you hey hey okay all right
don't look at gosh [ __ ] okay don't look
at you I guess is the the the story of
the day now okay so you're gonna be
there so I can close you off okay uh uh
uh sure okay oh I see oh okay all right
so he is it like a mouse-over thing yeah
oh it's either looking no it's a
mouse-over thing oh so if you're in a
dick position oh you're gonna be such a
douche oh you're gonna be a big reduce
today I'm never gonna be able to get
away from you
oh yeah you know you're an ulcer okay
he's gonna get bird meat bird likes you
I like your order favor oh yeah okay Yee
all right I'll take the take the power
Yee all right mr. Yee man I don't know
how to get rid of this coin oh hey Queen
no okay you know what huh begone foss
you go ahead and thought okay I can use
s there's gotta be another there's gotta
be another hotkey for like oh there's
gotta be another hot key fur for the
mask right or is it only Mouse that
might be only Mouse they might be a
douche okay he's gonna get sneered you
go oh hey stop that stop stop
go away he's gonna get right he's gonna
get snared right no no no you gonna how
wait wait wait oh yeah whoa hey wait oh
okay all right you're gonna be there but
I'm gonna be the boss of that
okay so smear no work on you for some
reason I don't know why but that's dumb
and you're dumb I'm the opposite of dumb
here you are dumb I'm done no dumb dumb
is not what I smart I'm smart smart
smart is what I am actually if you think
about it okay it doesn't seem that
laughs oh why hello it doesn't seem that
bad
silent ventilation mode is that for just
like just to reduce noise but then I'm
gonna run out of power
oh wait no wait the night is oh it's
already 5:00 a.m. oh yeah all right okay
all right sorry 5:00 a.m. I'm gonna beat
this oh you go be gone yeah he play with
fire and sometimes you get burned
no well I was gonna win oh all right
fine man all right I can't hit Kines
all right fine okay oh he was at a 10
oh that was a 10 that wasn't so bad but
that's gonna be a problem if he's
covering on my screen like that okay so
that was five nights at Freddy's 3 now
we're gonna move on to five nights at
Freddy's fo which is a lot of people
some some people's favorite so all them
nightmare characters and then we're
going to bring in
yeah that saddl do that'll do we're
gonna bring you guys up to five five
five five five am i I'm here Freddie
when Freddie's begin to accumulate in
your office shine your flashlight on
them before Freddie appears by his plush
from the prize counter when he appears
in the hallway to avoid his jump scare
he can't be stopped by the office door
well that's just a sack of [ __ ] ain't it
nightmare fredbear he's invisible to the
cameras and can only be seen when he
reaches your left doorway close the door
and his face to set him back into the
darkness
he's only invisible the cameras can be
to your right doorway close the door
hey Jack Oh chica when the office heats
up she will appear in both halls at the
same time close both doors to make her
vanish this won't work if the office is
100 degrees or more well [ __ ] nightmare
bangle purchases blush toy from the fly
scattered over the bright hall okay so
easy exact same as buying okay great
great I know about that one when he
slumped over in your office do not shine
your light on him when he is sitting up
however you must use your flashlight
okay I'll remember that here we go we're
learning we are learning learning is
super fun and important and I love to
learn okay he's not can't shine my
flashlight
okay so I can't see these guys on the
hallway right but I have to buy plushies
to serve wha-hey okay fine no shine okay
but I can't shine on that guy or else
he'll kill me cuz that's bad okay I need
tend to be able to get through those wow
No okay that's pretty close I don't
appreciate that okay no one's at my door
anymore coins and hema coins stop hey
stop stop he's not standing up yet so I
think I'm okay you're acting like a tit
[Music]
oh no I'm not doing that again I'm not a
fool me fool on you get fooled fool on
me ain't gonna fool me again you think
I'm a fool huh
you think I'm fool you think I'm fool
I've got ten coins good everything I
need but you weren't in the way I had
ten coins okay all right thank you why
are you why were you there so I would
have died anyway because I wouldn't have
even realized that the marionette was in
there so
whatever tries again let's get those
coins baby let's get those coins those
coins go to his coins yeah it's okay
they can simmer for a bit watch pot
never boils and you [ __ ] if I watch
you I'm gonna strangle you so it's kind
of like the same thing
all right oh yeah no no no okay all
right so I don't know
Oh was I supposed to look in the cameras
for those guys that might have been
cameras for those guys yeah that might
have been cameras for those guys I don't
want to count your teeth I Wow okay so
but the audio cue was there for that guy
the nightmare plushie I just wasn't
paying attention to
dude Mik teeth man I gotta I gotta do
that with the the keyboard I cannot do
if I didn't doing Mouse if I'm doing
Mouse for that one there's no way that
I'm gonna survive I need to get used to
getting the camera up without the mouse
don't see them there ah stop that did it
again okay
Oh Oh gonna buy the Bonnie plushie there
we go
okay so I got that right do I need to do
anything about her is it just gonna be
that way this is gonna be good I don't
know he it said he care
it said he care I said it can't be
stopped by the door so I'm just assuming
that that's legit and not just a joke
most of what I do in life is just a
goddamn joke okay simple as that
quick quick quick to the draw all right
oh hey oh I caught you there baby
okay I caught you so you can't be flappy
- flappy happy about the whole situation
with the camera because otherwise you're
just going to be caught in a bad
situation yeah okay
so note to self don't be so flappy wacky
about life whose is it you candy but
candy candy candy all day every day are
there two coves okay well there's two
stages I need to be pleased oh no I'm
not pressing you never pressing you
again your your benefits weren't even
that good anyway so screw you I mean
maybe if I was desperate and I needed
like a temperature drop you might be
good for that but I'm not gonna trust
you I'm gonna trust you at all I don't
know if there's like a timer for coins
of oh well okay I'm assuming that my
plushie worked because uh he was there
and now he's not there so you know
that's how that works out by you all
right easy as that okay you I'm not
doing the freaking keyboard shortcut I
have to
there you how's the bath positions not
right here
something's all right something some not
right something cannot put my finger
upon it but something something mean
right
oh my brain is just whoa I thought it
morning I thought I saw something
still I using the shortcut stone I doing
it there use that I haven't it brings so
much slower about it I'm so used to just
like flicking my camera
I'm just slamming it down as fast as I
can that's what I'm used to I did it
again
god damn it this is oh hey okay so I've
already bought you about you not doing
it screw you go to hell die die for all
I care okay getting better okay I don't
know if there's any benefit to keep
continuing to collect these coins but
I'm doing it so screw you if you think
that's stupid let me live my life I am
in the middle of a very stressful
situation and you try to get in the way
of what I'm doing that it's going to be
meant very badly for you so just let me
live my life
[Music]
Yeah right man that felt good man oh man
there that make me feel good that made
me feel good oh thank you thank you Roch
siffredi thank you okay first one I
wanna see I'm getting better at it why
we're gonna go for
we're gonna go for more of you cuz we're
gonna throw in some cuz a lot of you
guys are from pizzeria simulator and
yeah that's a lot it's a lot that I
lived it
Dale was so I'm gonna we're gonna have
all man consequences you you you you you
trashing the game what what they do I
love you guys but what do you believe me
we have scrap baby and then molten
Freddy just because it looks similar and
then we're gonna have a fun time with
all of you later okay all bad
consequence you see to catch a fish is
minigame otherwise you lock your monitor
up for a short time perches her plush
toy okay so she's plush toy bridge from
when the hallways got a listen shut the
appropriate door check his curtain to
see when the show is set to begin then
be sure to watch his cam at the exact
time to postpone the show otherwise that
is when your game will end what all
right
difficult to see on the vent radar he
will make his way towards your office
listen for a sound cue of tweet
squeaking metal then close the vent okay
appear opposite side of your office desk
cause you will move use a controlled
shock how do I don't know the control
jock won't Freddie climbs in the vents
but can avoid the vent snare listen for
his voice he then shut the door when he
gets through
alright let's see this I I'm the bass
ready as I'm gonna be I have no idea how
to beat these guys but I just
okay alright here we go hey how are you
doing okay so you're there that's great
that's so good
what am I looking for again coins well
those are gone
I hear you oh hey okay I don't know when
the show is gonna start or how I'm
supposed to know that know anything
actually I don't know what I'm doing it
Oh see got it oh hi oh okay wha
yeah might just not foot right whatever
I have no idea oh damn it I'm missing
coins okay I got enough I'll move don't
you move
[Music]
okay I didn't really thank you for that
it's gonna be a bit chained in it having
to having scrap douche there's just
gonna make everything yeah everything
that I've ever wanted to do awful show
time 1 a.m. 1 am okay all right well
I'll be sure to be there I will be you
will see me there I will be there and
you will be all like man you really were
there Wow all right
I don't know when 1 a.m. happens X's I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna look at you to
look at you just in case it turns over
sooner than
that's good okay I look over PA showtime
1 a.m. it I feel like now go away your
back cookie listen look I don't know
when 1 a.m. is gonna happen but it
better happen now there we go I delayed
you this shocked okay are we good we
gucci gucci gang we're Gucci alright
what's your new time - yeah see all
right I need a coin I need okay
don't move okay I think I care you think
I care ask me if I care I don't care I
care little bit oh I think that's the
right one okay you moved you move wait
no it's show time baby
no it's not wait no it's not okay what
is that okay show time soon oh hey
you're gone okay all right well that's
Showtime Showtime baby three two one
bingo Bongo no 44 and you said - did I
not see - right and I see okay I think
I'm forgetting some people aren't I am I
forgetting some people there was I feel
I feel like there was more people here I
didn't know what to do I just closed
everything and thankfully that works
so all right okay
oh hey oh god he's gone okay what am i I
am missing something all right I'm
absolutely missing something I know that
I'm missing something
I know a hundred didn't feel like I'm
missing something as 4 a.m. at 2:30 or
is that okay 2:30 so it's gotta be like
I can't do math in my head right now so
I have no idea tip okay I forgot the
plushies never got the blue shoes okay
all right right that's fine we're gonna
we did okay we didn't win that one but
that's fine okay so I'm gonna do we're
gonna do one more and I'm gonna go for
the whole host mortgage board here at
the bottom level of you [ __ ]
okay so we got trash in the gang who do
God knows what he'll pee when you see
him sitting in office click on him
quickly otherwise he will get in your
face with an air horn and to dating
sound sensitive am atronics happy frog
moves through the air ducts making your
way use audio allure to keep her in
place using me into the heater hippo
makes his way towards you your office
using the air ducts audio ler Peter to
push back the air ducts audio alert
holding pace or heater back ok so these
guys are mostly the same audio ler or
heater to keep them at bay
Orvil elephant makes its way towards
your office air ducts is not full by
audio lure can be pushed back with
heater ok occasionally activate and ask
for fast coins you can alternately use
the heater to cause them to malfunction
great when he appears in your office
search the cameras to find his guitar
flip the guitar to cinema
what do you I checked the left and right
hallways when the double click the wet
floor sign to place it on the same side
as rockstar chica she won't enter
when you see his bear click on it and
rock star fox he may offer you some help
it comes with risk however okay I know
that keep noise down his cymbals with
crashing faster and faster he says
they're pros in restaurant clothes he
had sometimes he can she will just
appear at random to distract you there's
no way to avoid her she could get at me
I don't know what she's gonna do Afton
he will attack once per night making a
lot of noise and causing lights to
flicker before attacking goes right that
door to block him he becomes active from
noise and heating's too far away from
the muse about to be suited by it but
the global means Bucks can calm him down
[Music]
oh hey hey hey man are you doing how you
doing you're doing ok so apparently
everybody's gonna be everybody's gonna
be in like everybody's either gonna be
[Music]
alright so that's just I gotta close the
right event when he does that okay so I
need fast coins that's obvious I need to
win some guy appears I need to get his
guitar hi okay that's new great are you
still there oh yeah
all right well that's never seen that
before
okay can I thank you okay I'm just gonna
look at the duct system cuz I don't even
know how this I don't even know how that
works I don't even know how the duct
system even comes close to working like
you said I could push him back with the
heater but not all of them did I have no
idea okay all right thank you for that
your input is invaluable and then now
they're not there now they're not there
why are they not there why they're not
there huh okay all right at least the
night is short so far so good
they don't all come at once they don't
know I mean this is just level one so
level one of these douches probably Oh
oh that's oh oh that's that's not good
oh he's not he's fine everything's fine
I think's fine okay everything's fine
keep this guy's that guy's going that
way did we I've got my sign he's uh
thumpy thump he's a good bad what's
happening he's upset he's not happy oh
oh I think that's damage I think it's
honestly your guitar that's great god I
gotta find it I'll find it I'll find it
boo don't worry about it I gotta find
your guitar I know you're just so upset
if you're if you're freaking blocking
his guitar right now I am so sorry
[Music]
yo you're what you're what means what
are you gonna do you're a level one I
don't know I think the balloon was
blocking her okay let's try this again
so I got to be more on the lookout for
that I gotta I gotta get in the habit of
flipping I don't know dad was I hate
that ah okay click on a path Oh
[Music]
you suck so bad you suck so bad you suck
so bad why why would you do that god
damn in which who and why who and why
who who am i dealing with why am i
dealing with them and what do you have
to say for yourself which is probably
nothing you have nothing
ah fine that's okay that's good
oh that's not good how do I have a get
rid of that I don't know that was a
double what would you do oh boy oh oh oh
no oh no that got rid of okay I'm like
shockingly good I mean they are level 1
I'm fully aware that they are all level
1 that's not ideal yeah but I shouldn't
be proud of what I'm - I shouldn't be
proud but you know I am okay we're gonna
cool it down yeah okay you be there you
do whatever you want - ah no no go away
I don't want you well maybe I don't
think you were supposed to be active
before and then suddenly you were and
you gave me the choice to fail and I
didn't
I hate you I hate you I hate you I'm
gonna win this one I think I funcle'
funcle' funcle' thunk okay I did it okay
but my a score has not been beaten cuz
they were all at level one okay now that
I did all of that now that he did all of
that now that he did all of that there's
also challenges I didn't mention that
there are challenges here oh that's a
nice basic challenge that's that's
pretty nice that's pretty good it's
pretty good but I'm saving these because
I'm still learning I am still learning
I'm still I'm still goddamn learning so
we're gonna do them all at level one and
if I can beat them all at level one that
means in my brain is held the useless
hostage of this game
make sense cool all right here we go I
don't even care we're going here we go
you're in there I gotta remember about
chica in the kitchen okay you're there
okay I gotta remember you hear that
that's closed good okay coins good good
it was watch you okay got you you're in
my way that's fine you're still there I
have to wind the music box well okay
you're there got a look at you you're
here got a look at foxy in the oh did I
accidentally change the music when you
oh I accidentally chain okay so if
you're not unhappy I can't change the
music I just leave you be so that's good
okay great
so we're gonna turn I didn't turn the
power generator on to so that's how that
was on my bad that was a big old my bad
put that there I'm gonna just like
there's so many of you but that's okay
that's ill
Hey look hey I'm sorry you were naked I
didn't mean to do that for you oh I
didn't mean to look at you when you were
nakey that's not why I came in there
okay who do we have here you get out of
here all right I remember Balloon Boy on
the ground over there
so look I'm sorry why do you gotta be
like this you're acting like I'm doing
this on purpose huh really really really
AM NOT I don't want to see okay your
show times at 2:00 a.m. I will rue oh
that's a problem not a problem I can't
deal with just a problem I don't want to
deal with okay you have not changed a
bit you have not a Dover ah you're funny
you not changed you're good okay you got
someone coming down the middle there all
right who will the hell Oh God
okay who you've not changed
there's gonna be a [ __ ] 1s duct claw an
audio lure over there then put that down
look for coins this is at 2 a.m. you're
fine
you know go away you Foxy's there look
at foxy I'm looking at you you close
that that's good alright looking at foxy
we'll come back at 2 a.m. 2 a.m. you
a.m. is the time to am looking at these
guys that guy this guy those guys
looking at all these guys looking at you
reset code adduct looks good go here go
away ok
looky here you're 2 a.m. Foxy's in the
cove look at foxy over there got it
I don't see nobody all right
still good love it kids coins I love
that good chance close that look over
here I don't see nobody Bonnie's in the
cove don't look at Bonnie ok come back
to 2 a.m. 2 a.m. 2 a.m. I've got it you
got it we got it
look at you ok Fox is in the cove got it
looked at that these guys good know
don't see anybody ah
catch got it ok yes oh you're back ok
that's good ok you're fine
damn douche
I'm Doge I'm a Doge oh [ __ ] I don't hear
God change music okay you're not changed
I need coins
okay one ass foot audio lure whatever
Rick put here or show times at three
okay that's good get coins yes sign okay
he's in the cove got it got it you here
there and bow my god okay look here
nothing okay foxes in the cove look at
foxy come back at three the time is
three don't forget it three wine that
Muzo box oh look look I don't see
nothing there ain't nothin for nobody
give me some goddamn coins thank you
shine look reset alright heats still
good you ah that was a risk I shouldn't
have done that without no one I put away
Bonnie's over there now don't look I
will not
I'll put you down I'll put you up how
the Frick literally you're just gonna
make it harder this is gonna make it
harder for me power hours well I had
that I had power alright one more try
one more try one more try one more one
more
one more one more one more one more one
more one more one more one more one more
one more
doct I saw Bonnie on the desk we're
gonna put an audio alert there event
here watch on show 1 a.m. you bet your
patootie I'll be there wouldn't miss it
for the goddamn war or old don't
everybody I knew by knew that bonnie was
gonna be there shine on you that's ok
you know what you know what
cuz ok ah city drink my ass oh you get
down you get down that's always what it
does like defaults to making the
marionette harder camera you get there
what time's show 3:00 a.m. oh it's
plenty of time I saw you peeking over
there
okay Bonnie's in the thing don't look at
Bonnie don't Bonnie look dead bone oh oh
oh hi your guitar I don't know where the
Frick that would be why do you think I
would know where your god dammit I did
it again did it again you know I wish I
didn't do it again but I'm dead
[Music]
one more lumber it that show times at
once macaron the smacky do right at one
don't look at bono okay
Fox owes back okay look at Fox oh he's
real pretty ones coming up but it's not
here yet
don't look I didn't set the audio Laura
sold but--at put this down
that's good put that up get more coins
one am almost round I remembered what
that was
please I'm soaking now one I am yet I
need more boxes too late too late got it
look at the show at Liddy did a little
it it I'm looking at you and you're
looking at me good
I hit the flashlight only thought I'd
about my mask I might have maybe done
did a good Lear what time's the show
tool that's a good time for a show was
that Dora Little Billy don't let the
bedbugs bite
don't bed my bug bite alright cool you
bet your thought I'll be there you know
I'm gonna be oh look you do that oh
looks like Bono's in the and the other
room over there me no need to look at
bono why would I look I'm not gonna look
I almost looked about I was like nah
don't look this stupid do you stupid if
you look oh wait no now I'm gonna look
because it's Fox oh they're not bono I
need more coins
a lot more coins I need to whine the
Muzo box
got it anybody here you go away okay all
right good golly gosh
oh I don't have enough coins I wa I'm
trying I'm really trying I need coins
there we go got it okay and Bonnie there
we go okay we're good okay I'm not
looking at you
deduct is okay okay okay we're good
we're good okay so Bono's in the place 2
a.m. is when I need to be in their face
you're there still good okay we're good
Fox those into place okay good okay
almost time for show this is no no too
early I guess go now that's not good Oh
three oh hi okay you know that's not
what I oh god I'm panicking again okay
three I gotta be there Bono's in place
it's not good you're still there you're
there you're there you're there you're
still oh you haven't moved I don't think
anyway oh that's that's faster okay
three ah no not through yet there's 350
that's when it'll be three okay yeah but
put the heater on move people back
[Music]
[ __ ] you ah Z okay you're fine
no oh God that's not possible
oh god damn Oh guitar guitar guitar
guitar and I need the I need more coins
and nipple coins any more coins oh my
god any more coins give me coins give me
coins it's fine
okay going no I forgot about the music
box
how could I forget about the musical
Brad my face okay mangles coming down or
nightmare mangle or whatever you want to
call that goes at 3:00 got a coin at
mangle spot okay got it
all right get away get away get away get
away now get away
I don't care okay anybody coming in over
see that whoa whoa whoa whoa I might
have been early on the
[Applause]
okay shows up three I got time
oh boy here we go time for a thing thank
you thank you that's exactly what I
wanted okay so that three is coming up
it's coming up coming up soon went up
sooner than I'd like
Roxy yeah boy a foxy oh wait
thought though three whole three ones
three I don't know in threes oh what the
heater uh AC on AC on what you gonna
love you and three two one look looking
huh with my eyes okay oh okay I got a
look at foxy Fox is getting pissed
that's okay he's still good there you go
away you're Bonnie's in the other room
oh my god oh don't do that
ones the other time you look at foxy new
time is four okay so not long from now
again I keep doing that thing where I
don't look at the I don't look at the
side always I get distracted
wibbly-wobbly do they get plenty of
coins plenty of coins
okay alright I can do this God it was
that one I forgot it was a one o'clock I
forgot it was it one oh that sounds like
a bad okay
do you dare I need more coins but I need
a okay you're fine that's fine
Oh tip my ass but I'm not afraid of you
Bonnie's in place oh [ __ ] where did you
go oh wow he moved Oh
[Music]
okay that's okay
oh whoa whoa whoa what the flipping okay
it's no different right there's no way
it's it's not different for some reason
I'm just in a different place I'm gonna
completely ignore that fact we're just
gonna like totally skate on by 2:00 a.m.
that's fine by me perfectly normal
perfectly normal okay great
Wow I'm so happy about that didn't look
at you
that's all [ __ ] you right there right
there right there right there right
there
get off my head and did you go there and
you go here looking at you and you okay
all right that's fine this is all fine I
don't like that I like to puppet my gosh
see okay I don't like to do it all of
this all this is bad
oh it is bad I have enough coins oh here
comes here comes big old [ __ ] boy it
comes [ __ ] boy bring up these mo you
flashlight okay I can do both of those
at the same
who's gonna buy out going to buy I was
going I was on my way to the store to
buy I was on my way to buy you didn't
let me buy I was gonna buy need to be a
little faster you know and they said you
were fun giant eager I didn't know that
it was going to be that kind of a fun
time you know so bad maybe that's a way
okay
you're coming down the way that's fine
you do your thing you're welcome good
thing I had so many goddamn coins oh
your guitar okay I'm really looking for
this goddamn guitar that's not there
[Applause]
where's where the where would it be
[Music]
could it be in anything any of the
cameras that work could it be an event
6:00 a.m. so I got to end the game
looking at him whoa I gotta end the game
with him ah
Frick I'm such an idiot goddamnit again
cuz I wasn't sure that's a stupid
[ __ ]
other died anyway cuz I wasn't able to
look at it I just get like these jumbo
boobs
okay I get looped up in jumbles I don't
know why whoa that's weird
okay okay well this might be a [ __ ] yeah
I can buy that okay we're okay you're
coming down whoa easy there sonny jim at
5:00 a.m. but it's getting real dicey
cuz this guy's so yeah he's very unhappy
with me
yeah he's oh hey whoa okay you're stuck
I guess which is kind of cool oh I
forgot
god dammit of all the I was 10 seconds
away I was 10
god damnit us 10 seconds away I mean I
probably would have been fine if I had
because I again like I panicked but for
some reason I panicked and I couldn't I
couldn't figure it out but that's fine I
got close it's just like there's so many
things would you forget one and then you
get jumbled but I think I got this at
least you know it's it's just the one
mode like it's really not all that bad
with one I can imagine this being a
goddamn nightmare with twenty I don't
even know how anyone would do this with
twenty but I'm gonna do my best right
now on one I'm gonna concentrate on that
I'm not gonna worry about twenty I'm
gonna worry about one
oh wait go oh I know with that let me go
haha that was real close
oh boy that was way too close 5 a.m. for
that that's coming real soon
what's I'm assuming that's this five am
yeah okay
oh [ __ ] okay get the mangle one quickly
thank you
foxy look at foxy you're there with
these ones don't get the music box let's
look at the vent system okay I'm just
gonna close that it's not ideal but you
know better than the alternative you go
out do he favor I didn't click on that
okay soundproof please I guess they're
blocking on that that's good okay good
good so that's good there got the plushy
for that guy shush shush shush shush
shush didn't even know god [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me [ __ ] you and then [ __ ] me point three
I didn't even know my mouse was over you
my mask was up god damn a dick god damn
a dick that god damn I'm a [ __ ] duck
a dick
[ __ ] damnit duck a dick god damn I
had duh oh I had that that was like in
the bag that was in the v bag the only
bag that was around it was in it I would
on it around it in the bag
[Music]
god [ __ ] damn it god [ __ ] damn it
god [ __ ] damn it done [ __ ] a gun
god [ __ ] that it was a [ __ ] oh
come on [ __ ] me if the show is at 6 p.m.
you have to end the game looking at Oh
God
Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] god dammit okay I guess that's how
we're gonna end this anti climactically
even when I win you don't let me feel
good about it I ran out of power god of
course you could let me win in the most
infuriating possible way god I don't
need your pity
I don't need your lucky pity win goddamn
man now is ultimate custom night one
2051 mode 50 of 1:1 level 150 is what
that was it wasn't that bad it's just uh
[Music]
it's just keeping things in your mind
the only reason I'm upset at all is not
because it's not because the game is bad
I'm not saying the game is bad at all of
the games too hard it's 50 what mutters
not that bad right here in my mouth it's
not that bad but the reason I'm upset is
because I said that I eat the beginning
of this recording I was like I would
have to beat 51 no no not this episode
because I was planning to live stream
the rest of this I'm going to be
live-streaming the majority this to get
through the challenges because it's
gonna take so long like like 20
different videos going 51 52 53 54 all
the way up to 50 20 so I'm gonna be
live-streaming this with you guys
I'll let you guys know when I'm gonna be
able to do that but that is I'm getting
good at making excuses it's fine the
game is fine I'm fine
it's fun in a way it's infuriating but
it is fun so I just wanted to say thank
you everybody so much for watching and
putting up with my rage and
my screams and just thank you guys so
much for being there for me and also I
wanted to mention a personal thank you
to Scott Cawthon himself he when I made
the video announcing what happened to my
niece he made a really nice post and he
didn't have to and that's what threw me
off so much I sent him an email but I
don't know if he uses the same email
anymore
but I sent him an email just thanking
him because he he sent out a message
that was just like the gate this games
coming out obviously and he wanted to
put it out there that you guys you know
hopefully you guys wouldn't bombard me
with a request to play this game while I
was you know away with family and I just
wanted to say thank you to Scott for
that because you know he didn't have to
do that you really didn't have to do
that but you did and that speaks a lot
to like I don't know it speaks to your
character and and it's not something
that I really appreciated and I know it
would have happened anyway and I know
you know you making that message it
wouldn't remove the world but it did
sway some people and you know it gave me
a little bit more space in terms of
focusing on you know just spending time
with my family so thank you Scott and
thank you guys so much like I said
beginning this video thank you for
giving me time on this and yeah I will
be live streaming this in the future and
in the very near future probably like
tomorrow I will be live-streaming it or
later tonight or whenever I feel like
spending some time with you guys and
it'll be a very relaxed thing we're
gonna take our time with this because if
I try to push myself like I did in this
video I will get upset and then I won't
be able to keep going so we're gonna
take it nice and easy I'll let you guys
know I'll create an event for it and
we'll have a lot of fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself it is
free so go get it off a steam it's
totally free and just thanks for
watching let me know he fought down the
comments below if you found any secrets
let me know down in the comments as well
because I'm sure there are secrets and
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]